bonsoir à
tous quand j'ai répété mon speed cet
après-midi devant ma petite fille de 3
ans au bout d'une minutes 30 elle s'est
levée la une
feuille couleur elle m'a tourné le dos
elle s'est mise à
dessiner par mesure de sécurité je
voudrais que vous mettiez vos crayons de
couleur et vos feutres en bout de table
on va passer les récupérer puis on vous
les restituera à la fin de la
conférence pourtant j'étais en train de
lui parler de superpouvoir j'étais en
train de lui expliquer qu'on avait tous
un super pouvoir sur
l'énergie simple claquement de Doig on
on
est je voulais lui dire que ce super
pouvoir se limite pas seulement à
éteindre et allumer la lumière c'est ce
que je vais mefforcer de vous expliquer
aujourd'hui
l'énergie elle est présente dans nos vie
quotidienne partout tout le temps la
plupart du temps on sen rend même pas
compte on a découvert le feu qui est une
source d'énergie primaire et qui a été
le fondement de notre civilisation on l'
d'abord utilisé pour se
réchauffer puis pour faire cuire des
aluments une bonne idée parce que je
sais pas si vous avez déjà goûté du MAM
fr pas
terrible et ensuite on a utilisé pour
fabriquer des outils et évoluer au fur à
mesure
depuis notre civilisation a évolué mais
s'est toujours appuyé sur une production
et des besoins d'énergie toujours
croissant la première révolution
industrielle s appuyée sur charbon la
seconde sur le pétrole et on croit
beaucoup ici en orpcalé la 3è révolution
industrielle on a beaucoup souvert de la
deè on espère de la première aussi on
espère pouvoir profiter de la 3ème
révolution industrielle qui s'appuira
sur les énergies renouvelables en tout
cas aujourd'hui on a besoin d'énergie
donc pour s'éclairer aussi pour se
chauffer paraît même des régions où on
en a besoin pour se rafraîchir mais en
tant qu'ois con ça on a besoin aussi
pour se nourrir j'ai visité une
brasserie hier vous allez me dire oui
par de la bière c'est pas se nourrir
j'ai des copains qui vous aont le
contraire en tout cas vous avez pas idée
de la quantité d'énergie dont on a
besoin pour boire une bière avant qu'on
puisse boire une bonnere il faut arroser
semer d'abord arroser récolter
transporter le malt l'orge le sucre
ensuite il faut les mélanger les brasser
les passer de Cu en Cu de cuve en cuve
les reconditionner et enfin seulement on
peut saavourer cette
bonne alors pendant longtemps les
citoyens se sont tenus un peu à l'écart
de ces questions là chaque nouvelle
énergie était un progrès technique pour
la plupart elle coûtait assez peu et ça
nous apportait un niveau de confort
satisfaisant et depuis quelques années
depuis le crack pétrolier à peu près à
peu près les années 60 70 on s'aperçut
que
l'énergie c un sujet qui concernait la
géopolitique la politique l'économique
le culturel et aussi
l'environnemental risque beaucoup de
parler d'énergie lors de la prochaine
conférence climat qui commence dans 10
jours à
Paris et donc pendant longtemps pour mes
grands-parents par exemple l'lectricité
venait de la prise
murale pas trop de question on appelait
même ça en France la fé
ricité simplement aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas si simple que
ça qu'il y a énormément d'enjeux comme
je vous le disais et que l'énergie est
un bien commun dont on a absolument
besoin il faut absolument que ce besoin
que cet accès à l'énergie soit garanti à
tous si l'énergie est un bien commun ça
veut dire qu'elle m'appartient aussi un
et si elle m'appartient un peu ça veut
dire que j'ai une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de cette énergie de la
production de la consommation
d'énergie alors comment exercer cette
responsabilité moi je vois trois grands
moyens d'action
pour premier moyen il est trivial on
parle de plus en plus c'est consommer
moins vous avez certainement en tête pas
mal d'exemples très simple de moyens
d'économiser l'énergie je vais donc
passer
rapidement non je vais pas passer
rapidement parce que même si ces moyens
sont simples beaucoup d'entre eux ne
sont pas utilisés par exemple vraiment
curieux de savoir c'est une vraie
question que je vous pose est-ce que
vous coupez l'eau du robinet quand vous
penez une douche pendant que vous vous
savonnez qui d'entre vous le
fait c'est pas mal en même temps vous
pouvez me raconter n'importe quoi j'irai
pas
vérifier deuxième moyen d'agir c'est
euh par exemple de couper leséveille
vous savez que les veilles de vos
appareils la box Internet la télévision
euh l'ordinateur
ça peut représenter jusqu'à 10 % de
votre consommation d'électricité je
repose la même question qui d'entre vous
le soir en se couchant coupe leséveille
de ces appareils
électriques pas
gagner pourtant c'est très simple il
existe des multiprises avec un
interrupteur on a même pas besoin de se
pencher on économise sa propre énergie
on tend la jambe et hop 10 % d'économie
je sais pas si vous connaissez beaucoup
de moyens de faire des économies aussi
simples on tend la jambe et hop 10 %
il y a d'autres exemples comme ceux
mettre un couvercle sur une casserole
qui chauffe dégivrer son réfrigérateur
une fois par an très pénible mais ça
vaut le coup et cetera et cetera et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ça permet
de faire des économies et aussi de
diminuer son impact sur l'environnement
ça c'est la première façon
d'agir la deuxième un peu moins triviale
c'est qu'on peut aujourd'hui consommer
mieux vous avez peut-être remarqué que
depuis quelques années maintenant les
fournisseurs d'énergie vous indique d'où
vient l'énergie qu'il vous fournissent
est-ce qu'elle est locale est-ce qu'elle
est d'origine renouvelable comment ils
s'approvisionne il y a même certains je
connais bien Ding des lunettes une barbe
un peu rousse qui crée des coopératives
où il rassemble des consommateurs des
producteurs d'énergie qui fixent le prix
ensemble et qui crée un circuit court et
local d'électricité vous pouvez bien
évidemment selon vos cission choisir
tout autre fournisseur d'énergie mais
vous avez le choix vous pouvez agir par
votre acte de consommation c'est la
deuxième façon
d'agir la troisième c'est produire son
énergie vous connaissez tous maintenant
les panneaux photovoltaïques une
technologie qui arrive à maturité qui
s'est très fortement développée depuis
20 ans encore plus depuis 5 ans elle est
utilisée dans le monde entier et elle
fonctionne même ici dans le Nord où on a
pourtant plus de soleil dans le cœur que
dans le
ciel ça fonctionne mais ça demande un
petit peu peu d'investissement ça
demande un petit peu de place tout le
monde n'est pas propriétaire de sa
maison tout le monde n'a pas une voiture
orientée plein sud tout le monde n'a pas
les moyens d'investir seul 20000 € pour
produire son
électricité c'est pourtant un des
préceptes de la 3è révolution
industrielle que chaque bâtiment puisse
produire son énergie et l'échanger avec
les autres ça reste aujourd'hui un peu
compliqué pour la plupart d'entre nous
par contre ce qui est possible de faire
aujourd'hui c'est de se regrouper pour
produire son é et ça c'est le Chang tel
que vous me voyez moi le repropriétaire
d'un panneau
photovoltaïque il n pas chez moi puceque
j'avais pas la place il est sur la
toiture d'une école ici à l'île sud
l'école Malo j'ai investi 500 € j'ai un
panneau à moi j'ai même pu baptisé il
s'appelle ramix
Panoramix alors comment on a fait en
fait on s'est regroupé avec une bande de
copains
on est allé voir la ville de Lille on
leur a dit est-ce que vous avez pas des
toits disponibles nous on aimerait bien
produire notre énergie mais on a pas de
place chez nous on a pas assez par
contre ensemble on peut le faire ils
nous ont aidé on a rencontré les
directeurs d'école on a choisi celle de
l'Î Sud aussi une vocation pédagogique
très importante ça nous a permet de
créer du lien et puis en plus ces 500 €
me rapportte un petit peu chaque année
c'est plus que livra c'est pas
grandchose
plais on peut voir un petit peu plus
grand nos amis breton par exemple
qui aiment bien l'autonomie euh se sont
regroupés pour dans un village en tout
cas à bégane se sont regoupés à 1000 se
sont mis à 1000 personnes et ils ont
investi dans leur propre parc éolien
aujourd'hui ce parc éolien est en
service il produit pour 2500 foyers ils
ont donc gagné en autonomie sur leur
accès à
l'IM autre exemple cette fois-ci en
Allemagne à hunig il y a plein
d'exemples en Allemagne mais j'ai choisi
le mot que j' savais pas proncé Henig
cette fois-ci ce sont 450 habitants d'un
village qui sont regroupés pour créer
leur propre réseau de chaleur ils ont
créé une coopérative avec les
agriculteurs du village les agriculteurs
déposent leur déchets sont bien contents
de s'en débarrasser déposent le déchets
dans un méthaniseur fait fermenter s
déchets agrico fait du gaz ce gaz
distribué dans un réseau de chaleur
alors il alimente pas tout le village il
alimente 45 foyers du village etes 45
foyers réalisent 40 % d'économie par an
par rapport à le ancienne facture
d'électricité
on dit souvent que l'herbe est plus
verte ailleurs et on dit souvent aussi
en France que l'énergie est plus verte
ailleurs et ça c'est en train de changer
aussi et c'est à nous d'incarner ce
changement nous sommes je crois une
centaine aujourd'hui dans la salle à 100
si on se regroupait on allait voir la
direction de yesseg qui peut-être
présente dans la salle on pourrait
peut-être investir collectivement et
faire en sorte que l'école crée une
partie produise elle-même une partie de
ton électricité je va vérifier pendant
les répétitions à côté des ruchers
là-haut des toitures plat on peut y
aller on peut même créer une Nasso comme
celle qui organise ce ce ce ce ce super
moment qui chaque année pourrait créer
une petite unité de production il y a
vraiment beaucoup de choses à faire
c'est le message que je voulais vous
faire passer
aujourd'hui le pouvoir qu'on a sur
l'énergie est réel vous pouvez consommer
moins vous pouvez consommer mieux et
vous pouvez produire votre énergie seul
ou
collectivement vous pouvez en parler à
vos amis
à vos
collègues à vos
éluse vous pouvez en parler aux
association avec lesquêes impliqu et
vous pouvez sur Internet vraiment un
levier d'action
extraordinaire ma réussite à
moi spech chacun d'entre vous puisse
dans les jours dans les semaines dans
les mois qui viennent réaliser une
petite action sur l'énergie parce que ce
sont les petites habitudes et les
petites initiatives qui font les grandes
transitions je compte donc sur vous
faites preuve d'énergie prenez le nord
et n'oubliez pas d'éteindre la lumière
en sortant
merci